we've already seen alcohols in many of
these videos but I thought it was about
time that I actually made a video on
alcohols all on alcohols now alcohols is
the general term for any molecule that
fits the pattern some type of functional
group or chain of carbons o H and they
use the letter R and I've used it before
R stands for radical and I want you to
confuse this R with free radical means
completely different things are in this
form really just means a functional
group or a chain of carbons here it
doesn't mean a free radical this just
means it could be just you know
something attached to this o H right
there
now another point of clarification do
not think that anything that fits this
pattern is drinkable do not associate it
with the traditional alcohol that you
may or may not have been exposed to
traditional drinking alcohol traditional
drinking alcohol drinking alcohol is
actually ethanol alcohol is actually let
me write out the molecular formula ch3
ch2 and then Oh H this is what is inside
of wine and beer and hard liquor or
whatever you might want you do not want
to drink and maybe you might not
actually want to drink this either but
you definitely do not want to drink
something like methanol it might kill
you so you do not want to do something
like this you do not want to ingest that
might kill or blind you this might do it
in a more indirect way so I want to get
that out of the way and just so we get
kind of a little bit more comfortable
with alcohols and we've seen them
involved in other reactions we've seen
hydroxides acts as nucleophiles and sn2
substitution reactions create alcohols
but what I want to do is just learn to
you know get comfortable and really make
sure we know how to name these things so
let's just name these molecules that I
drew right before I pressed record right
over here so over here like everything
else we always want to defy the longest
carbon chain we have 1 2 3 4 5 carbons
so it's going to be pent so it's going
to be
tenth and there's no there's no double
bonds so it's a pentane so I'll just
write pent pentane right there and we're
not going to just write a pentane
because actually the fact that makes
it's an alcohol that takes precedence
over the fact that it is an alkane so it
actually the the suffix of the word will
involve the alcohol part so it is Penta
null so let me I'll do that
the Penton all that tells us that it's
an alcohol and to know where the O H is
grouped we'll start numbering closest to
the O H so 1 2 3 4 5 so this sometimes
it'll be called 2 Penton all and this is
pretty clear because we only have one
group here only one o H so we know that
that is what the 2 applies to but a lot
of times if people want to be a little
bit more particular they might write
pent pen ton pen ton to all-to-all and
this way is more useful especially if
you have multiple functional groups so
you know exactly where they sit this one
is harder to say to Penton all is pretty
straightforward now let's try to name
this this beast right over here so we
have a couple of things going on this is
an alkyne it is an alkyne we have a
triple bond
it's an alkyne we have to bromo groups
here and it's also an alcohol and
alcohol takes precedence on all of them
so we want to start numbering closest to
the alcohol so we want to start
numbering from this end of the carbon
chain and we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
carbons so this is going to be this is
an acht
this is we want to call it an octane but
because we have an alcohol there we want
to call this an octane octet me let me
make it very clear
so we acht tells us that we have eight
carbons now we have to specify where
that triple bond is the triple bond is
on the 5 carbon you always specify the
lower number on between of the carbons
on that triple bond so it is acht 5 5
EIN that tells us that's where the
triple bond is and then we have the the
OAH on the 4 carbon so 4 4
for all and now we have these two bromo
groups here on the seven carbon so it's
seven it's seven seven die bromo
die bromo acht five nine for all and
this would all be one word let me can
make sure that you realize that this
should be connected I just ran out of
space so that's probably about as messy
of a single after name but just showing
you that these things can be named now
let's think about this one over here in
green so we have one two three four five
six carbons so it's going to be a hex
and it's actually ended all single bonds
so it's a hexane it's a cyclohexane but
then of course the hydroxide or the the
hydroxy group I should call it takes
dominance so it's it's a it's a hexanol
so this is a cyclo cyclo hex an all and
once again once again that comes from
the Oh H right there and you don't have
to number it because no matter what
carbon it's on it's on the same one if
you had more than one of these O age
groups then we would have to worry about
numbering them now let's finally let's
just do this one right over here so once
again what is our carbon chain we have
one two three carbons and we have the
hydroxy group attached to the one and
the three carbon so this is going to be
this is pro is our prefix it is an
alkane so we would call this we would
call this and there's a couple of ways
to do this we could call this one comma
three propane Pro pin' dial actually I
don't have to put a dash there Pro
pinned dial and over here we would add
the e because we have the D right there
so it's pro pinned dial if it wasn't
dial it would be pro pin' all you
wouldn't have the e d and the I there so
this was specified we're at the 1 and
the 3 carbons we have the hydroxy group
or this could also be written as propun
propane propane 1 3 dial and once again
the die is telling us that we have
two of the hydroxy groups attached to
this thing but either of these things
are ways that you would see this
molecule named